اعتراف مذهل من كاثرين
دوقة كامبريدج حول
الأمومة ، الأم الملكية لثلاثة أطفال تعترف بأنها
تكافح تمامًا مع نوبات من
ذنب الأم وتتساءل أحيانًا عن
قرارات الأبوة الخاصة بها كاثرين والأمير
وليام يفعل والداها ثلاثة أطفال
يبلغون من العمر ست سنوات الأمير جورج
أربع سنوات  - هي الأميرة شارلوت
وطفلها الصغير الأمير لوي وقد انفتحت
عن كونها أماً في بودكاست بريطاني ،
هل تعاني من ذنب أمك
بسبب نعم وأنت تعلم حتى هذا
الصباح أنني ذهبت إلى زيارة الحضانة ، نعم
جورجي ، كيف يمكن أن لا يقرأ
أو  حرة ونفسها في المدرسة هذا
الصباح ، لكن لا يمثل ذلك تحديًا مستمرًا
أنت هنا من حين لآخر من أجل
الأمهات حتى الأمهات اللواتي لا يمارسن
بالضرورة تدريب Paulding في
اتجاهات الاضطرار إلى التوفيق بين الحياة
والحياة الأسرية التي لا يمارسنها  أشعر أن
هناك دائمًا شيئًا ما دائمًا ما
يكونون بالضبط ليسوا دائمًا نوعًا ما
تشكك في قراراتك
وأحكامك الخاصة وأشياءك  مثل ما
أعتقد أن ذلك يبدأ عندما يكون لديك طفل